foreign
[Music]
presents gnome Chomsky speaking on
Linguistics and philosophy
April 12 1995 University of New
Hampshire at Durham recorded for Radio
free Maine by Roger licener we now join
Mary Clark as she introduces Noam
Chomsky
Mystics at my t a man who has been
described in the New York Times as quote
arguably the most important intellectual
alive today
Professor Chomsky has some very
interesting things to say about
political issues as you'll learn if you
come to his second lecture this
afternoon at four o'clock but in this
lecture he's going to talk about
Linguistics which is his primary
scholarly field
in fact the field of linguistics has
been completely transformed by his work
of the past 40 years
Professor chomsky's first book syntactic
structures was published in 1957.
in this book he posed a new and very
ambitious question
what do we know when we know the English
language
of course Scholars had been studying
language for a long time and had
developed an extensive terminology for
talking about parts of speech
grammatical functions such as subject
and object and so forth but what Chomsky
did that was new was to set out a
detailed formal system that tried to
mimic the ability of English speakers to
generate all and only grammatical
sentences of English
this was of course a project that could
never completely succeed but in
attempting to carry it out Chomsky
developed very important insights that
opened the way to even more interesting
and ambitious questions
the grammar he set out in syntactic
structures made use primarily of two
sorts of rules
phrase structure rules which describe
how words are put together to form
phrases and Transformations which
describe the movement of constituents
out of their normal positions
so for example when we ask a question
such as what can you see
the question word what appears at the
beginning of the sentence even though it
stands for the direct object of the verb
and direct objects in English normally
follow the verb I can see the Blackboard
this illustrates a transformational rule
of English called wh funding that takes
a questioned element out of its normal
position in the sentence and moves it up
to the front
Chomsky and his students soon observed
however that a question element cannot
be pulled out of just any position in a
sentence so to use an example of
chomsky's paralleling the statement they
kept the car in the garage we can form
the question
which garage did they keep the car in
but given the statement they kept the
car that was in the garage we cannot
form the question which garage did they
keep the car that was in
in other words there are constraints on
the circumstances in which the rule of
wh funding can apply and similar
constraints have been found to hold for
other sorts of rules in fact as
investigation proceeded the constraints
began to assume greater importance than
the rules themselves if the constraints
are stated precisely enough then the
rules themselves can be very vague and
general move something
the constraints and other principles
then tell us what can move or must move
and where it should move to
but since these constraints and
principles are very abstract in nature
and there is no direct evidence for them
in the surface form of a sentence
another question inevitably arises
namely how do we learn these constraints
and principles
chomsky's answer is that for the most
part we don't learn them constraints are
principles of this sort are not
something we learn they are part of what
we bring to the task of learning they
are part of the human faculty for
language
thus chomsky's original question what
are the properties of a grammatical
sentence of English begins to give way
to more interesting and even more
ambitious questions such as what do
human beings bring to the task of
learning a language and what is a
possible human language in other words
what properties does a language have to
have in order to be learnable by a human
child
Chomsky himself continues to lead the
investigation of these questions during
the course of his career he has
published some 15 books on linguistic
Theory and I didn't try to count the
number of important and influential
articles linguists all over the world
now work in the framework that he
developed
and because chomsky's work has important
implications for the general study of
the human mind he has also had enormous
influence in the fields of philosophy
psychology and cognitive science
he is indeed one of the great thinkers
of our time and I'm very proud to
introduce Professor Noam Chomsky the
title of his talk is current issues in
linguistics and philosophy
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you care where this goes
over here okay how's that can you hear
me yeah okay
nice when technology Works rarely
happens uh
well you actually heard her at a good
talk I think about what Linguistics is
about so that's a lot of things I don't
have to talk about what I would like to
do is to uh sketch is to try to give
some of the flavor of the sort of work
that's going on now in areas that at
least to my judgment are the most
exciting and most important others no
doubt feel otherwise uh but I'll talk
about what I I want to I'm not going to
be able to discuss it in any detail but
I'd like to see if I can try to give a
sense of what it's about what kinds of
questions are coming up and uh uh what
sorts of questions still aren't coming
up because they look impossible which is
an interesting distinction and other
things of that sort however to make any
sense out of this it's necessary as far
as I can see to
think about where it came from and I
know I'm constantly rethinking where it
came from as in the other Sciences you
begin to understand what was happening a
long time ago the more you get to know
so people do Newtonian physics today
quite differently from they talk about
Newtonian physics and History of Science
quite differently than they did say 50
years ago because new things are
understood which makes the questions
look different and the intuition is
different and the and so on and the same
is true in this corner of the Sciences
uh so questions look different that
we're asked they're asking for a little
more volume
how's that
you hear me in the back yeah okay is
that all right yeah if it isn't the you
know yeah or something yeah
uh the I'll try to keep my eyes up there
uh I was just saying that the I want to
if you didn't hear what I was saying
before I'm going to try to give
something of the flavor of current work
but against the background of some
partial reinterpretation of where it
came from since things tend to look
different the as you understand
the problems differently uh as was
mentioned this kind of this direction
and the study of language and the study
of Mind altogether uh took on a sort of
a pretty new course after the second
world war actually to be more accurate
it returned to an old course that had
been forgotten completely forgotten uh
and approached it from another point of
view which hadn't really been possible
before that's again something not at all
uncommon in the history of science so
say take major moments Newton believed
in transmutation as you know and spent
most of his life on Alchemy and he had
good reasons for that it wasn't silly
the reasons were the basic assumption
that the world was all constructed out
of everything in the world had this it
was constructed out of little tiny
invisible objects corpuscles that were
the building blocks and anything could
be made from anything up from those
blocks so he could make just as with
bricks you can make one building or the
same bricks you can make a different
building with these things you could
make water or you could make a tree and
so on and so forth and in fact they even
had experimental evidence that water
could be turned into a tree so the
origins of chemistry come from an
experiment falsely demonstrating that
fact but rather convincingly
demonstrating it uh so the uh in fact it
wasn't for a century and a half that
people found out what was wrong with the
experiment but the
uh so here here is an idea that says
every every entity in the world is
constructed from the same things and
therefore if you rearrange them you can
turn anything into anything else uh that
was finally abandoned around uh you know
about 1800 or so uh with the conception
of elements that you study in chemistry
you know so sodium is different from
Iron but of course in the 20th century
it's been revived so there's a certain
sense in which indeed everything is
constructed from the same things and
which indeed the sense in which
transmutation is indeed possible at
least in principle and maybe even in
fact uh but and here this is another I
mean that's a huge case this is a small
case where some of the earlier ideas
which were abandoned because they seemed
completely
feasible or crazy have been revived and
in fact turn out to be pretty sensible
if looked at from a different point of
view the traditional idea that was
sort of in the air and occasionally
articulated uh over the years from about
17th century on until it died in the
early 20th century uh was that was
captured in a slogan of one famous
linguist philhealth and Humboldt that
language involves infinite use of finite
means
short the brain is finite plainly but
you you can make infinite use of
whatever resources it has infinite just
means you can keep going on and on with
new objects without any limit uh and
that that part is true it does involve
infinite use of finite means uh that was
an aspect of a an observation that led
to the classical theory of Mind and Body
uh earlier Descartes had
based his conception of two different
substances mind and body on the fact
that humans uniquely had this capacity
to make infinite use of finite means in
the use of language whereas he argued no
other
no automaton could do this uh and no
other organism could do it so there's
got to be some fundamental divide
between humans who have a mind and other
organisms and other and automata and so
on that don't in fact that is the
classic Mind Body problem uh the uh this
notion goes on efforts to deal with this
problem remained and continued for years
maybe the last representative of this
tradition is uh Otto yes person and
we're linguists to the early part of
this Century uh who has a interesting
book which
people are starting to read again they
didn't read for a long time called
philosophy of grammar came out in 1924
which is sort of the last theoretical
exposition of this point of view uh in
which he said the task of the language
he said every every person develops in
their mind somehow or what he called a
notion of structure
for their language and that notion of
structure guides them in constructing
free Expressions free expressions are
typically novel Expressions that you'd
say in an appropriate circumstance and
that other people somehow understand
even if they've never heard it before or
anything like it before and you can do
this without limit and then he said well
the task of the linguist is to figure
out what the notion of structure is and
how free expressions are constructed for
it and furthermore to figure out how
that notion of structure gets into the
mind of the speaker of the person who
knows the language given just exposure
to various uh kind of chaotic and
actually pretty pretty limited
experience those that are indeed the
problems they Remain the problems uh
some of them uh and and they were pretty
much forgotten they were dropped by the
early part of this Century as the study
of language and anthropology and
psychology went off in a different
direction a direction that was
considered much more scientific uh the
scientific direction as most science
does and correctly narrowed the scope uh
it narrowed the scope the particular
other things well sometimes that move is
correct is The Right Move sometimes it's
the wrong move you never know until
you see what happens so when Galileo
restricted the study of motion to things
like walls rolling down inclined planes
he was ridiculed because things like
that don't happen in the world and
besides what about all those other
things like flowers growing and people
perceiving things and so on and so forth
but that turned out to be the right
narrowing out of it came a lot of
understanding often the narrowing
doesn't turn out to be the right one and
I think this was one of those cases the
Linguistics and anthropology and
psychology from the early part of this
Century focused on things that they
could pretty much observe on
Arrangements of sound maybe Arrangements
of words uh what you discovered very
quickly there was a great expansion of
the range of materials that were looked
at so people began studying widely
different languages that they never
looked at before and it looked as if
well standard slogan in the mid-1950s
was languages can vary arbitrarily uh in
every possible way any array of sounds
and words could be a language there's no
limits uh how do you acquire language
well the general assumption was he just
it's just a habit you do it by rote the
way you sort of walk across the street
or something like that and in fact the
big problem about the 1950s for language
acquisition was why it takes so long uh
it was a problem called over learning
since it's so trivial how come it takes
a child years and years before they can
do this Elementary thing when they can
you know sort of walk across the room
very fast so the problem is you know
over learning how see notice this exact
opposite of Say Yes person or Descartes
problem uh how you get infinite
knowledge uh the uh and this was all in
the behaviorist tradition and so on and
so forth one aspect of this was European
structuralism which has very little
impact in linguistics but had huge
impact on other disciplines literature
anthropology and so on I it was
concerned with the patterns of sounds
and the way they interacted with one
another and so on and so forth again a
very strict narrowing of attention which
was not without results but turns out to
really miss most of the important
questions like the questions that were
asked up through say yes person after
the second world war there was another
approach that suddenly came along that
was a kind of a high tech approach that
came out of the new technology and the
computers were just coming along
artificial intelligence was coming along
information Theory had just been
invented and out of this there was a lot
of euphoria about what's going to come
out of you know technology and
understand mathematics and so on and it
was in fact generally assumed take this
book syntactic structures that was
mentioned if you look at it you'll
notice that the first part of it is
devoted to
an argument showing that the theory of
automata and information Theory and all
this sort of thing can't do anything
they have nothing to do with language
the reason why it's there is because
what was thought at the time this was
undergraduate course notes at MIT
engineers and scientists and the it was
constant it was always assumed at the
time this is the answer to every uh the
sophisticated psychologist assumed that
the engineers assumed that you know
mathematicians did and it was just that
was clear enough so you disprove it very
quickly it's one of the advantages of
being clear uh other things were vager
and harder to disprove like they say
behavior is psychology which had even
less Merit in my opinion but uh the uh
so so there were around the 1950s there
was there was structural language and
its various varieties there was the sort
of high-tech approach and the tradition
had pretty much been forgotten but of
course it remained in the schools so for
example when you study traditional
grammar uh you were studying the
empirical side of the old tradition
if you look at if you're studying say a
second language say you study Spanish
and they teach you you know how to make
sentences and so on uh that's the
empirical side of the old tradition and
in fact it was assumed by traditional
grammarians the esperson was a major
traditional grammarian and he and others
assumed that they were indeed giving a
comprehensive account of the language so
it was generally assumed that if you
read a you know
time to read a 10 volume grammar of
English or Spanish or something you
would know the language it was also
assumed in parallel that if you if you
looked at a dictionary say the Oxford
English Dictionary you know the one look
at with a magnifying glass you could
find the meaning of a word so you want
to know the meaning the word River
tree or
City or desk or something or you know
some more complicated one look it up in
the dictionary and it'll tell you it was
also assumed that the dictionary is
comprehensive and that indeed the
grammars are comprehensive well both of
those beliefs turn out to be totally
false uh the dictionary tells you almost
nothing the only reason why people can
why we can use dictionaries is because
we already know the answers and the
dictionary gives you just enough hints
about what you couldn't know so that
using the knowledge you already had you
can build up the rich concept that in
fact goes along with the word and very
much exactly the same is true of the
structure of sentences or the examples
you heard are perfectly typical uh
people thought they knew how to form
questions because there was a rule there
and the traditional grammar that said
you know move the question word to the
front but as soon as he began to look it
turned out that what people knew about
forming questions was something
completely different uh and you could
show that easily by experimenting it
ramifies all over the place and in fact
none of the rules that are presented in
traditional grammars come even close to
describing the phenomenon they get what
they but they're very useful they give
hints to people about things that they
couldn't know idiosyncrasies of a
language that you can't know the kind of
things that a child would have to learn
uh and then the person who has all the
intuitive knowledge somehow stored in
there can figure out the rest uh so the
example of let's just take the example
that was given forming questions by
taking a
question word like what or who and
putting it in the front well it that is
something that a child can't know about
the language that is being presented
because language is just differ in that
respect some put it in front some don't
put it in front they just leave it there
and there's no way of knowing that
that's arbitrary that's like not knowing
whether tree is going to be pronounced
tree or bound there's no way of knowing
that so you have to hear it and then you
know uh similarly you have to hear that
the language you're being exposed to is
one that moves
question words to the front uh so you
know you're speaking English and not
Chinese or Japanese which leave them
down
where you interpret them the uh
interestingly welcome back to this but
so that's a respect in which languages
just differ so of course the grammar has
to tell you that just as information
from the outside world has to tell the
child that uh but uh all this other
business you know like why you're not
allowed to say uh
whatever the example was uh
we found the car that was in what did
you find the car that was in that kind
of thing yeah sure that you know already
because you're a human being and it's
part of the nature of a human being to
have that kind of knowledge which turns
out to be a very interesting kind of
knowledge same is true about
dictionaries so I don't know picks any
word you like it doesn't matter takes a
river since I mentioned it there's a
thing that flows by my office called the
Charles River uh the uh if you look up
the definition of river in a dictionary
it'll tell you something in fact it'll
tell you enough for a speaker of Spanish
to figure out what river means in
English on the other hand it won't tell
you what river means that you have to
bring to the uh to the dictionary and
you can easily test that for yourself by
simply asking questions like uh when
would it to under what conditions would
a modification of the Charles River
still be the Charles River
uh how do you what's technically called
individuate Rivers what are the
properties that make two things the same
river let's see well it can't be the
same molecules because they're flowing
they're always different so it's
obviously not that uh is it the fact
that it follows a particular course Well
it can't possibly be that because there
are certainly there can if the Charles
River was re-rooted let's say around MIT
because they wanted to build a road uh
it would still be the Charles River
right under some conditions not all
conditions but under some conditions it
would still be the Charles River uh
suppose it was rerouted so that it
didn't even go out to the Sea like I
suppose it ended up in one of the lakes
near Cambridge because you know they
wanted to build a reservoir or something
uh well that would still be the Charles
River although it flows completely
different now doesn't even go into the
sea uh suppose they decided to reverse
the course of it that's happened not
here but as far as I know but it
happened in the Soviet Union they one of
their massive you know
destructive projects was to reverse the
flow of a major river
well it was still the same river you
know you know even though the water was
going the opposite direction
uh does it matter what's in it
well to a certain extent but not too
much I mean I'd hate to think what
consists of whether Charles consists of
you probably if you fell into it you
wouldn't survive very long but it's
still the Charles River I was in Pisa a
couple of years ago and there's a thing
that flows through Pisa which is still
called the Arno river which is some kind
of yellow mixture of chemicals from
Upstream somewhere it may have a little
bit of H2O in it still I don't know but
it's still the it's still the Arno and
in fact you could do all of these things
at once and keep the same river you
could maybe it's a hundred percent
chemicals now that was 15 years ago it's
probably only 90 chemicals but suppose
that it turns out to be a hundred
percent chemical zero H2O I they the
courses change completely and in fact
reversed it could still under certain
circumstances narrow circumstances in
fact be the same river so whatever our
concept of river is it has all these
properties uh and incidentally the same
true of things like water inside the
river there's a common belief in fact it
pretty much dominates contemporary
philosophy of language and philosophy of
mind and it's like a Dogma that a water
is H2O that that's the meaning of the
word water that water more technically
is in our minds something which has the
same Essence as this particular thing
over here and same Essence is something
that science tells and it does it's H2O
well that can't possibly be even close
to True whatever water means it's not
that and we know it very well when you
start you're not going to find this F in
the dictionary but you know it as soon
as you start thinking about it so let's
imagine for example that we have pure
H2O and a couple over here okay pure H2O
well that's obviously water although
incidentally when you ask people they
uh in experiments they estimate that in
pure H2O they say it's only 98 water I
don't know I don't know why but that's
the Judgment people give but the uh so
anyhow pure H2O is pretty close to water
let's say uh the uh
suppose that you take a tea bag and you
put it in the water and it slightly
changes the content so if a chemist
looks at it he would say it's a little
different uh well that's not water
anymore that's tea if you ask for a cup
of tea and somebody gives you water you
get mad and if you ask for a cup of
water and somebody gives you tea you get
mad that's not what you asked for so
this thing isn't water anymore it's tea
all right now suppose let's imagine
another circumstance suppose some you
know
biologist comes along and figures out
that tea happens to be a terrific way of
removing bacteria from water and they
decide to build instead of putting
chlorine in the reservoir they put in a
tea filter okay so the water goes
through the tea filter and comes out
your tap and let's imagine that I got
another cup here which is pure pure H2O
that went through a tea filter from the
reservoir well what's that well that's
water just like the stuff that's coming
out of the tap now is water even if a
chemist couldn't tell the difference
between the two cups you know one of
them H2O with a tea bag dumped in it and
one the stuff coming out of the tap
which happens to pass through a tea
filter uh we know the difference one
though they're they're physically
identical you know even molecule by
molecule identical uh one is T and one
is water so whatever water is it's not a
substance it's something that it's it's
a it's a mental construct of some kind
uh that's true of names as well remember
the Charles River the Charles River is a
name uh and in fact every name is like
that uh it's some complicated metal
construct well without pursuing it any
further these are things that everybody
knows nobody's taught if you tried to
teach anybody these things first of all
we wouldn't even know what to teach them
because nobody knows it's bear these
questions are barely beginning to be
studied uh but uh certainly no child has
ever taught it if you tried to teach
anybody you would just confuse them uh
they try to teach a child these things
about you know tea and water they're
totally confused uh and the same is true
of and that's true of every word of the
language and it's true of every sentence
of the language uh if you try to teach
people studying English say
Spanish-speaking people if say you think
of course in Spanish and they tried to
teach you the way questions are actually
formed in Spanish you know all these
things about when you can move the word
and when you can't move it and so on you
would be completely confused you'd never
figure it out on the other hand if they
just tell you well move it to the front
then you know all the answers because
you're a human being and you've got all
the answers built in so the fact of the
matter is that the comprehensive
dictionaries and the comprehensive
grammars uh presuppose everything that
we're trying to figure out they don't
answer the questions they just
presuppose the answers to the questions
they're basically presupposing human
intelligence uh and if you want to know
what human intelligence was well you
know
nice to know what's presupposed but
that's the question I'd like to answer
so traditional comprehensive grammar was
saying lots of interesting things about
Expressions but it was saying pretty
much what is not interesting for
somebody who wants to know what the
human mind is like or what the language
faculty is like because it's
presupposing all of that unconsciously
uh well you know science really begins
very typically when you start when you
get the ability to be puzzled by
extremely simple things
like if it seems obvious that an Apple's
falling to the ground because you know
where else should it go that's its
natural place uh you don't get physics
it's only when you get puzzled about the
fact that the apple is falling to the
ground instead of flying up or that
things hold together instead of flying
all over the place uh or for that matter
the opposite that all the matter in the
universe doesn't converge into a single
Point since their subtraction uh it's
only when you get puzzled by simple
things like that that interesting
questions arise and you try to find
answers and that's what happened about
50 years ago 40 50 years ago uh for the
first time people started being puzzled
about things that look obvious and as
soon as he looked at them they were
anything but obvious and it turned out
there were some quite complicated and
intricate answers well that was the
atmosphere about 1950 it was possible to
there was an effort to pick up again the
traditional questions but from the start
nobody even knew that they had been
asked before everything had been
forgotten uh it was like a gap in
understanding it's only later that the
people began to discover what had been
said before well why did it become
possible to ask these questions around
1950 but not say 50 years earlier 200
years earlier the answer is that there
had been some new discoveries in formal
Sciences in mathematics and so on that
clarified the concept of infinite use of
finite means that looked very mysterious
before that how could you have infinite
use of finite means but a partial answer
I stress partial answer to that came out
in in mathematics and you know what came
to be called the theory of automata the
theory of algorithms or the theory of
computing and so on with uh girdle and
the church and touring and others a
concept of computability was produced
that answered some of these questions it
it made it possible to understand how a
finite system can have infinite can can
express an infinite number of things and
it there's a very clear concept by 1950
in fact there seemed to be an absolute
notion of computability such that no
every way you try to approach it you
always came down to the same concept and
that was common knowledge by that time
and that made it possible to re-ask the
old questions from start now you could
ask something about how you form free
expressions with a finite mind or how
you can make infinite use of finite
means but here you have to be a little
cautious because it's only one aspect of
that traditional question that could be
faced uh the question that Descartes and
yes person and Humboldt and others were
asking was a question about how you
speak
how do you when how do I do what I'm
doing now what I'm doing now is forming
new expressions and you're hearing the
expression so how do we do that it was a
question about performance and here
here's where the questions of Mind came
up the fundamental questions of mine the
question that Descartes asked is how can
a person though not a parrot or an
automaton presumably how can a person
produce new Expressions which are not
caused by the circumstances
so so you're not forced to produce that
by your inner State let's say or the
things around you but even though
they're not caused by the circumstances
internal and external or nevertheless
appropriate to the circumstances that's
the crucial issue how do you continually
do new things that are neither that are
not caused but are appropriate and are
coherent and that other people
understand as coherent and appropriate
and that evoke thoughts in the hearer
that the hearer could have expressed
himself or herself if they'd thought
about it that's the problem it's the
problem of uncaused appropriate coherent
Behavior without limit
I sometimes called the creative aspect
of language use now that's a different
problem from another one how can a
finite system characterize an infinite
number of expressions
to characterize an expression doesn't
mean just to list it it means to give
its form its meaning its sound
everything you know about it how can an
infinite amount of information be stored
in a finite brain that's a different
question from the question of how you
can carry out the creative aspect of
language use it sounds like the same
question and until the 1950s it was
thought to be the same question but once
the concept of
computability
what's technically called generative
Funk procedures once that was clarified
these two questions separated and one of
them is studyable the other one's not
studied
That Remains the case so the one that's
studiable is the one that uh that has to
do with the nature of the information
that's stored in your head somehow in
the language faculty of your brain which
is like an organ of the it's kind of
like the kidney as far as we know and
working of the body uh so in the
language faculty of the brain whatever
it is or wherever it is nobody knows
exactly but it's there uh the language
faculty of the brain has stored in it an
infinite amount of information about a
particular linguistic system whichever
yours is whatever mixture it is uh on
the other hand there's another question
that is how do you use it how do you use
it in ways which are appropriate to
situations but uncaused by situations or
and on caused by your internal State
those are turned out to be quite
different questions one of them is
investigable the other is not the one
that you can investigate has led to the
modern study of language the one that
you can't investigate is in exactly
where Descartes left it total mystery uh
incidentally this is not just true of
language it's true of every aspect of
Psychology and Physiology so suppose
you're studying say vision
uh there's a lot of work in the last 50
years on the visual system and it's all
about things that happen between the
retina and the striat cortex so it's
about the mechanisms of vision
it's about how stimulation of the retina
leads you to see a cube rotating in
space but nobody asks the question how
do you decide to look at a sunset let's
say
that's a question about Vision but it's
not a question about that can be asked
so nobody bothers asking it I mean it's
a question right but it's a question
that we can ask and just stare at and
you know and kind of confusion not
knowing where to go because again it's a
question of appropriate voluntary action
and those questions are just not within
our range of in inquiry or similarly
suppose you're say studying there's work
on turns out to be extremely hard to
explain how to account for the fact that
I can say reach over here and pick up an
apple let's say
that's a very hard thing to do it's
extremely hard to get a robot to do it
turns out to be quite complex you know
the mech they think the motor actions
and coordination and control and so on
that are going on pretty complicated and
there's very interesting study about how
you do it I mean it seems easy just
reach over and pick up the Apple but to
figure out what you're doing turns out
to be extremely complex and there is a
big study and an interesting study of
the mechanisms of motor control and
programming and coordination but nobody
studies the question of why I decided to
pick up the Apple you know why did I
pick the Apple up and not my watch or
something that's not a question that you
can study and that's a question that's
analogous to the question of use of
language and in fact if you think across
the board that's the way it always goes
uh when you talk the things that can be
studied are questions about about
mechanism about how knowledge is stored
uh how internal programming takes place
uh how you know one kind of
representation say a mapping of the
retinal mapping can turn into another
one let's say
concept of the seat percept of a cube
rotating in space those things have been
subjected to inquiry and we know a lot
about them but a whole class of other
things of which the use of language is
one they remain where they always were
and remember those are the ones that
were traditionally exciting uh those are
the ones that led to the traditional
mind-body problem uh I'll come back to
where the study of what we can study
went from there but first an aside on
the Mind Body problem uh what happened
to that problem
well is that problem still around well a
lot of people seem to think it's around
so there's a big you know there's what's
in fact sometimes called an Orthodoxy in
philosophy uh which is that things can
be reduced to uh the Orthodoxy is that
philosophical questions about
the mind and mental activity and mental
events and so on should be reducible to
the material world to something about
the physical world which is supposed to
give you a resolution of the mind-body
problem and there are big debates about
whether you can do it or you can't do it
and so on uh these debates are rather
curious because the Mind Body problem
doesn't exist and it doesn't exist
because it was demolished by Isaac
Newton three centuries ago uh Newton
didn't have anything to say about the
the cartesians had a theory of mind and
a theory of Body In fact science
altogether had a theory of body it was
called the mechanical worldview and it
was very common sensical the mechanical
it probably is there a common sense
picture of the world uh the common the
and that was science you know the top
scientists of the day oyens and others
were trying to develop a mechanical
worldview which shows the world as a
machine that was a big job show that the
world's a machine
uh and then describe came you know his
argument was well yeah the world's a
machine in fact everything's a machine
except the creative aspect of language
use and some other things like that
which don't seem to be duplicable by
automata uh so they're that's the second
substance that's mine well what happened
to that picture what happened is that
Newton showed that nothing is a machine
in fact that's exactly what he showed if
you think about it uh what Newton showed
much to his distress I should say and to
the distress of everyone else who
thought it was kind of like a reversion
to traditional mysticism is that the
entire world is immaterial
uh the world is governed by immaterial
forces uh what were in fact called
occult forces uh anybody knows anybody
as Newton pointed out it's an utter
absurdity which no one with the
slightest scientific he said
philosophical but I mean scientific uh
understanding could believe that one
object can influence another if they're
not in contact that is a total absurdity
and it certainly is a common sense
absurd it just happens to be true
uh he showed it was true universal
gravitation showed that in fact what is
an utter absurdity is true and that was
quite disturbing but the effect of it
was to show that the world isn't a
machine in fact nothing's a machine uh
even simple terrestrial and planetary
motion aren't mechanical the mechanical
world picture was demolished uh it's
commonly said now you know it's common
these days in philosophy and elsewhere
to deride
theories of the Mind as being a ghost in
a machine and we've got to exercise the
ghost but what's forgotten is that
Newton exercised the machine
uh so that he didn't he left the ghost
untouched he had nothing to say about
the theory of mine he in fact assumed
that somehow if we ever figured this
stuff out it would incorporate mind but
it was left as a total mystery and it
remains a total mystery in fact it's
just gotten more mysterious since uh as
physics has introduced more and more
crazy ideas uh to try law and to try to
account for what goes on in the world so
there is no notion of material and there
is no notion of physical and there's no
notion of body and so on hence there
cannot be a Mind Body broke uh what
there is is just various aspects of the
world and you try to understand them the
best you can and unify your
understanding as best you can but I
don't think that anyone has formulated a
coherent version of the mind-body
problem since uh since the 17th century
so it's not at all clear to me at least
what people are arguing about when they
say they're they think that the mind can
be reduced to the body or they don't
think it can or whatever since there's
no notion of body the debate doesn't
seem to be without any uh but the
problems remain I mean the problems of
how you of the mental aspects of the
world they remain uh and they remain to
the most for the most part unsolved uh
we can pull out little pieces of them
and get insight like the nature of the
mechanisms that underlie infinite
knowledge there we can get a lot of
insight but the main questions about the
mental aspects of the world like for
example the question of coherent
appropriate meaningful action which is
apparently uncaused as far as anyone can
tell that problem remains and it remains
completely mysterious all right that's a
side now back to the part you can study
uh so now we're at a point where you can
resurrect the old problems but from a
new point of view uh look at the way in
which infinite knowledge is stored in a
finite brain figure out what the
mechanisms are as you looked closely it
quickly turned out that the things that
were thought to be simple are in fact
completely not understood like what's
the nature of a river or how do you form
questions totally not understood all the
information we had about it was just
data you know that was hints to a person
who already knew the answers and we're
trying to figure out the answers I at
that point serious inquiry begins and it
led to an immediate Paradox uh instantly
first first thing that happened already
by the 1950s as soon as you started to
ask the questions a flood of data came
along which no one had ever suspected
about how sentences are put together
exactly as happened when people started
studying what happens when something
rolls down an inclined plane turned out
that all kind of weird things were
happening that no one had ever guessed
like you know speed depended on the time
not the distance and things like that so
uh and here too tons of information came
around that nobody ever noticed before
and you know great effort was made to
try to give an accurate description of
it at least to try to present
precise rule systems would that it would
at least assign the right meaning to the
right Expressions over some sort of an
interesting range well it turned out
that the effort to do that is I mean the
one example you heard is typical as soon
as you start to do it you find very
funny things and you've got to
complicate the rules to account for them
and the rules we're getting proliferated
all over the place you take a look at a
kind of grammar that was written in the
1950s and thousands of rules for all
sorts of different things and
furthermore they were different for
every language
so if you ask how you form a question it
looks I mean if you give the precise you
know if you try to lay out the details
of what questions look like in English
and what they look like in French and
what they look like in Chinese and so on
they just look completely different
in fact if you look at questions in
English and relative clauses in English
they look totally different and in fact
every two things you look at just look
completely different and the rule
systems were exploding all over the
place and they were different for every
two languages and so on well that's what
happened when you tried to achieve what
was called descriptive adequacy just
give an account of the facts at least in
a precise fashion without appealing to
uh unto what is understood without
relying on what is passively understood
rather trying to spell it out same in
the case of dictionaries I should say uh
now so that that's the way that's that's
the direction you were forced to go as
you started paying attention to the fact
on the other hand it was completely
obvious that it can't be correct uh the
reason it can't be correct is because of
the problem of acquisition of knowledge
uh children acquire the idea that
the problem is over learning is
completely crazy the problem is how
anybody knows anything uh if you look at
the actual data available to a child it
is so limited and sporadic that to get
anything out of it is kind of miraculous
it's like the question how an embryo on
the basis in fact very much like the
question of how an embryo given
nutrition can become a chicken let's say
well obviously the nutrition doesn't
tell it how to become a chicken because
a different embryo given essentially the
same nutrition might become a you know a
whale or something uh the uh so it can't
be in the nutrition because the
nutrition doesn't doesn't direct the
development it's got to be something
about the embryo that's determining it
and the same is true of the problem of
language acquisition the data is much
too sparse to lead to any uh and
something very complex and specific is
coming out like what you have in your
head
and somehow that's got to be inside you
you know so it's pretty much the same
problem geology like it is the same
problem uh the uh and the same thing
happens for say postnatal development
again people don't think seem to ask
much about it but if you think about it
the same kind of question like say you
know every person within some very
substantial range undergoes puberty at
roughly a certain age okay
how do you do it I mean it can't be some
instructions from the environment it's
not peer pressure you know it's not
our kids are doing it I better do it too
or something like that uh it's got a and
on the other hand there's no
instructions around I mean it's true
that if the nutritional level is low
enough so you're practically starving to
death then it won't happen but within a
very substantial range it's going to
happen and it's going to happen in a
very special way well that's postnatal
in fact probably after the period in
which language is already settled but
somehow it's got to be internally
determined and in fact every biologist
assumes this I don't think anybody knows
a thing about it but everyone assumes
that it's internally determined then
just has to be and it has to be because
there's just no information around
that's forcing this specific development
to take place and the same is true of
language acquisition and in fact
everything you look at so on the one
hand you know that languages have to be
basically identical because they must be
derived from the fixed internal
knowledge and we're not internally
programmed to know English or Spanish
everybody knows that so there's some
fixed internal knowledge which is
determining virtually everything about
the language
uh and some details around or making it
one language or another and they've got
to be basically the same on the other
hand when you look at them they're
totally different and so complicated you
can possibly learn them from the data
around that was the problem Paradox uh
to account for uh the fact that language
can be acquired you had to you knew that
they were going to all turn out to be
essentially identical but when you
looked at very simple in fact because
you've got to pick them up on the base
of very restricted data on the other
hand when you looked at the actual
materials they look completely diverse
and it did indeed look as if they could
vary in every possible way well uh the
answer to that the way to answer that
problem was understood immediately and
it set the task for quite some time the
way to answer it is to try to take the
massive complicated data like say
forming questions and show that it's
only superficially complex that actually
if you pursue it deeply enough you'll
find principles that determine how
things work which are hidden you're not
going to see them in the data and that
those principles will interact somehow
to yield the complexity of the data even
though the principles are fixed and the
reason why languages will look different
is because there's some little variation
here and there that make the principles
work differently if you take a very
intricate mechanism and you make slight
changes in it here and there the output
of what it does can look totally
different even though there's only tiny
little changes going on uh and that it
had to be something like that so that
started a search for principles of
computation basically an organization
and structure which had the property
that if you could find them and you
could abstract them from the data what
was left was very simple in fact what
was left you hoped would be something
like move anything anywhere
in fact that's pretty much what turned
out to be the case uh so move anything
anywhere look is the right kind of
principle uh but it's only going to work
to give you examples like what you heard
and million others like them uh if you
know something about the structure about
the properties of structures that can be
formed and you know conditions on the
way these things can move and so on so
from about 1960 that was the main
direction of research and it kind of
converged uh it was making progress for
20 years around 1980 it did converge in
a totally different picture of language
and that's really the first major change
in the conception of language in about
2500 years I think this is an old
subject and if you go back to ancient
India there were things like what we
call generative grammars that is
detailed
grammars that formed expressions and so
on but of the type of early generative
grammar and traditional grammar uh the
picture that came out around 1980 is all
this stuff sort of finally began to fall
together was a very different one uh it
was a picture that said languages don't
have rules at all
the traditional story what you learn
when you you pick up a grammar of
Spanish it has a chapter on how to form
questions in Spanish or how to form verb
phrases in Spanish these grammars are
traditional grammars are construction
based and rule-based they assume that
there's certain constructions like
passive or relative clause or verb
phrase and so on and then there are
rules for handling those constructions
that every traditional grammar is like
that and that goes back thousands of
years and early generative grammars were
also like that like there was a rule for
forming relative clauses in English and
it was a very complicated Rule and there
was another rule for forming questions
in Spanish and that was a very
complicated Rule and so on and a rule
for forming verb phrases in German and
that looked totally different it was
another rule so these were these
grammars like traditional ones were
rule-based and construction based the
picture that finally emerged from what
I've been describing assumed that there
are no rules at all and there are no
constructions at all constructions are
just taxonomic artifacts there is
nothing like relative clause or question
or verb phrase any more than there's
something like terrestrial mammal or
household pet now when I say there's
nothing like household pet I don't mean
you know your cat doesn't exist what I
mean is that household that is not a
biological category and terrestrial
mammal is not a biological category in
fact neither is tree it's not a
biological category uh it's a maybe a
human category but it's not a category
in the world you know just like rivers
or in our human categories but not
things in the world in our sins each
particular instance of a river is but
that's a different question that's like
your cat exists uh so it seems to turn
out that the traditional constructions
like verb phrase or passive and relative
clause and so on are just like household
pit their taxonomic artifacts they are
things that fall together when
principles happen to interact in a
particular fashion they you get these
things but the same principles the very
same principles when they interact in a
slightly different fashion they give you
one of the other taxonomic artifacts but
it's the same principles uh that's the
picture that began to emerge no
constructions no rules uh just very
general principles well how do languages
differ
uh because they're obviously not all the
same well the idea was that they
differed only in a very narrow in fact
probably finite enough clearly finite
number of ways uh and the ways had to do
with what are called parameters slight
points of variation
which are very local in fact they're
probably localized in not only in the
Lexicon in the category of words but
even in certain very narrow properties
of words in what are called formal
properties of words like case like all
the stuff you study in fact when you
study another language like case and
inflection and agreement and so on or
you know what you do with the wh phrase
and things like that there's a small
number of ways in which languages can
differ and they have to do with
particular formal properties of certain
kinds of words in fact if you look even
more closely it seems to turn out that
all languages are the same in these
properties but they're just different in
how it comes out the mouth
so go back to the example that was given
at the beginning of forming questions in
English you you do take this question
word and you put it in the front so you
say what did you see in Chinese you
leave it where it was but if you look
closely you find out that English and
Chinese give the same interpretations of
expressions
so for example let's take a slightly
more complicated case uh if you take a
sentence in English like
uh Mary wants to fix the car with a
wrench let's say
and you want to ask
you didn't hear what I what she fixed so
you say what does Mary want to fix with
a wrench and I can say the car uh or
maybe didn't hear how she did it and you
ask how did Mary want to fix the car and
I say with a wrench uh that's okay and
you can do the same in Chinese even
though you leave the words in place on
the other hand suppose instead of
wants to you had wonders whether to
okay slight change so now we have the
sentence Mary wonders whether to fix the
car with a wrench
okay and now you didn't hear the car and
you asked about it and you say what does
Mary wonder whether to fix with a wrench
answer the car
and suppose you do the Hal case uh how
does Mary wonder whether to fix the car
and that doesn't work at all either
you're asking something about wondering
you're not asking about fixing so the
answer the question can't be how does
Mary wonder whether to fix the car
answer with the wrench that doesn't work
well the fact is it also doesn't work in
Chinese even though you leave the wh the
question word down below so apparently
in Chinese they're doing exactly the
same thing we are uh and something is
blocking moving the question word to the
front and we have a good idea what it is
uh but in Chinese they're just doing in
their heads it's not coming out the
mouth okay so they're running through
the same computation apparently but only
a certain piece of it is getting
articulated whereas in English the
computation itself is getting
articulated but in fact Chinese and
English look exactly alike and as far as
we know every language looks exactly
alike except for the fact that languages
differ in which piece comes out the
mouth well that's a case where something
comes out in English and doesn't come
out in Chinese it works the other way
too as you can imagine so if you've
studied say Latin or Greek or German you
had to spend a lot of time learning
about inflections you know case endings
and nominative and accusative and all
that kind of stuff uh English Chinese
doesn't you don't hear them at all
English you barely hear them you hear
them for pronouns but nothing else like
I saw John and John saw John saw Mary
and Mary so John
in Latin one would be nominative and the
other accusative and the opposite but in
English they sound the same on the other
hand there's extremely good evidence by
now that English has exactly the same
case system as Latin except it just
doesn't come out the mouth you can see
the effects of it when you begin to
figure out how case systems really work
and the consequences they have for
interpretation of sentences and what is
a sentence and so on you find you get
exactly the same things in English you
get in Latin almost exactly not quite
exactly uh and the same in Sanskrit and
the same in Finnish which has even more
cases and the same in German and so on
and so forth so it looks as if English
and Chinese have all the cases it's just
that they're not coming out the mouth
we're doing the same computations in our
heads but it isn't getting articulated
and in fact it seems that an awful lot
of the difference among languages just
has to do with which properties are
getting articulated it looks as if the
computations are all the same
like in all languages you have a
collection of building blocks things
like words and you have a couple of very
simple operations for putting them
together and they meet very general
conditions and the languages seem to
differ wildly because different things
are coming out the mouth
but in fact it's the same computation so
if a martian say was looking at us the
Martian would assume that all humans
speak exactly the same language with
extremely trivial differences among them
pretty much the way we assume that all
take one species of frog we say look
they're all the same although the frogs
May well think they're very different
from one another uh and in fact be
interested in the differences and we're
interested then of course in the
differences among humans not what's
identical about them that we just kind
of take for granted but if you look from
the point of view of a scientist like a
rational Martian looking at us the way
we look at fruit flies or something uh
we would probably look essentially
identical you know extremely slight
divergences and in the case of like this
aspect of language that part is now
becoming clearer you know I wouldn't
argue it's totally understood but it's
certainly becoming clearer it's becoming
reasonably clear that there is a fixed
set of principles that determine a
unique kind of computation for all
languages so they're basically all
identical and that the apparent
differences between them have to do with
things like which what comes out the
mouth and it seems to vary almost
entirely in the so-called formal
properties things like inflection or
question word or something like that not
in other things like even it looked for
a long time as if the ordering of
languages was very different so English
it's like subject verb object in
Japanese it's subject object you know uh
English it's preposition noun phrase in
the room at Japanese it's noun phrase
preposition
room in you know in fact Japanese looks
like the mirror image of English
virtually so it looked as if they just
differ you know there's a so-called
parametric difference that says English
goes to to the right and Japanese goes
to the left uh well you know it turns
out that even that isn't obvious there's
a new book that's just come out by a
very good linguist Richie Kane MIT press
just published it who argues that in
fact they're all identical even here uh
and there's some other tiny difference
that makes languages look as if they
have different orders and that's not
proven but it's you know he's got good
evidence and it wouldn't be at all
surprised if it does come out to be
right uh the more you look the less
languages seem to differ from one
another uh and uh notice that this has
been achieved without losing the
descriptive adequacy quite the contrary
the descriptions are much closer to
correct than they ever were and
furthermore they're far more
comprehensive because one of the things
that's happened through this period is
that you know every time a new
theoretical Insight came along about how
to organize the system it immediately
stimulated new questions empirical
questions uh which then came up with
totally new data which nobody had ever
guessed at before like these things
about Chinese they weren't even nobody
ever know noticed them until about 10
years ago the that it works like English
and the interpretations uh well that's
brings us pretty close to where we are
now uh this so-called principles and
parameters approach is the first
legitimate theory of language ever
uh it's the first theory that at least
offers a what I mean the details aren't
by any means all known but the picture
is not implausible and to some extent
understood it's the kind of theory which
allows an answer to the question how
does anybody know a language
it's the first theory that ever allowed
an answer to that question and the
answer would be well you just have to
figure out which things are coming out
the mouth you know and that's fairly
straightforward like you hear the cases
or you don't hear the cases yeah
uh or you hear the question word in
front or you don't hear it in front so
it's kind of as if the child comes to
the language with the whole story in
place just like you know undergoing
puberty is already in place or growing
arms not wings or something it's in
place that's part of the internal
instruction uh but you've got some
things that aren't totally in place so
you have a kind of questionnaire you
know like finite number of questions
question one do I pronounce the cases or
don't I pronounce the cases okay Quest
and that's an easy one to answer you
hear it pretty fast uh do I put the
question word in front or do I leave it
in place that's an easy one to answer
computations go on the same way and they
have intricate results but you know
which way you do it and if you have
let's say whatever it is you know 83
questions like that uh you can kind of
check off the answers and once the
answers are checked then the whole
system works okay something like that
looks like the right picture
incidentally I've left not a huge piece
of it how do you know what sound goes
with what meaning in the case of words
so how do you know the tree is tree and
not bound that of course you have to
learn like that's arbitrary but that's
pretty simple if the whole concept tree
with all of its richness like River and
City and everything else if that's all
in place and the range of possible
sounds is almost entirely in place then
about all you have to learn is how
they're linked
and again that's pretty simple and it
better be pretty simple because we know
that children are learning words at the
rate of about one an hour uh during the
peak periods of language development
about two to six and to say that
children are learning words at a rate of
about one an hour and you notice that
the learn a word means to know
everything about the word River
or water and I just barely touched on
the complexities of it if you're
learning that kind of thing at one one
an hour you're learning it on one
exposure
no more than that uh so one exposure to
the word must be sufficient to put in
place all of this wealth of information
and therefore it obviously all has to be
there and the only thing you have to be
learning is you know well okay how does
this link between sound and meaning goes
so one big piece of language learning is
that kind of thing another piece is
answering these questions and a few
other things but that ought to be enough
to put the language in place uh well if
you so this is a legit you know it's
probably the wrong Theory because every
Theory anybody ever has is always turns
out to be the wrong Theory but it's the
right kind of theory you know it's the
right kind of theory for language and
for the first time ever and indeed the
right kind of theory for some aspect of
cognition of the nature of our knowledge
and understanding also for the first
time ever maybe for the only time ever
because nobody knows how to ask these
questions in other areas
but notice that once you've got the
right kind of theory I'll end with this
bringing us up to the present uh then
new questions arise uh the question that
comes up is basically
to put it sort of metaphorically how
perfect the system is language
notice that the language faculty is
sitting there in the head somehow in the
mind we don't
know where or how in the brain but
somewhere in the brain if there's this
language faculty it's got external
conditions that it has to meet
like the language faculty has to
interact with the sensory motor system
okay like you have to be able to you've
got to get the muscles of the throat and
mouth to work it has to link up with the
perceptual system it also has to link up
with whatever systems there are that get
you to do things with language like
talking about rivers or asking questions
or telling jokes or whatever whatever
you do with language is some sort of
systems of the mind and the language
system has to link up with those so in
fact there's a whole set of external
conditions on the language faculty uh
and it just it has to provide
instruction somehow an expression of a
language like you know
Mary wanted to fix the car with a wrench
that instruction as it's computed in
your head that object as it's computed
in your head has to provide instructions
to the articulatory system the
perceptual system the action systems the
referring systems and so on what are
sometimes called intentional system it
has to provide instructions to all those
things which is what enables you to use
language notice we're not getting to the
hard question how do you use it just
what kind of instructions are there and
how do they interact that's the part we
can study uh well those external
conditions we don't have really good
understanding of but we have a ton of
data about
so there's a ton of data about the way
the articulatory system works and the
perceptual system works and the cons and
the intentional system we don't nobody
understands very much about the use of
language but you know a lot about what
sentence means what and how it's used in
particular circumstances you've flooded
the data about that and that massive
data even with limited understanding
imposes very strong empirical conditions
on what the language faculty must be
like
well the question that you can now raise
for the first time is how well does the
language faculty meet those external
conditions does it mean it the way a
really smart engineer would have
designed it or does it meet in a crummy
way you know that's the question so how
perfect is language in the sense of if
you just look at the external conditions
and you ask what's an optimal solution
to those external conditions how closely
does language approximate it
well it turns out apparently turns out
remarkably closely
as more on this work of the last few
years in fact so a lot of it just coming
into publication there's more and more
work coming along which seems to
indicate that language is very close to
a perfect solution to this problem
uh now that has a definite meaning I'm
sort of leaving it metaphorical but it
has quite a definite meaning it means
and like at time I could spell it out
but one aspect of this is it appears to
turn out that the computational
procedures of language uh
have to be that they meet certain
optimality conditions meaning if you
start with a bunch of words and you're
trying to form an expression you must do
it by the most optimal means and some
other means of forming an expression
which would give you something
meaningful is just blocked if there's a
more optimal computation so there's just
some things you just can't think because
there's a more optimal way of
constructing an expression from the same
words things like that these uh
or sometimes called economy conditions
on computation leave you with the
following picture of language the
computational system which has its fixed
principles not only produces sounds with
meanings but does it in an optimal
fashion and any other way of doing it is
blocked because it's not optimal which
means that there are some Expressions
that can't mean what they ought to mean
or can't be said because something else
is blocking now that property of
language is pretty it's pretty
remarkable if it's true and it looks
like it's true a lot of things can be
explained that way it's remarkable for a
number of reasons one reason is you
simply do not find things like this in
the organic world
the organic world is a very messy affair
uh so a I mean that which is very lucky
I mean the reason say why if you're hit
over the head with a crowbar uh you can
continue to function very often and even
go back the way you were whereas if you
hit a computer with a crowbar it's
finished forever you know the reason is
that the biological world is a very
messy Affair uh you've got a lot of
redundancy built in a lot of alternative
Pathways a lot of crummy ways of doing
things and so on and so forth uh so
therefore if something goes wrong
something else may go right you know uh
the inorganic world isn't like that
it's got to be you know you pick a an
atom let's say and you change something
it's some totally different thing you
know or or if you take a machine and you
you know pull out one uh you know one in
one element say one chip the thing is
dead you know it has no ways of
compensating uh the biological world
it's also the biological world is also a
mess because of the way biological
organisms develop they just evolve under
extremely messy conditions uh the way
many biologists put it is Evolution's a
tinkerer it sort of does the best it can
with rather rotten under rather rotten
conditions which is one of the reasons
why you know contrary to sort of
Reader's Digest style of biology every
biologist knows that organisms are very
badly designed
from an engineering point of view
they're usually extremely badly designed
this is something that all of us know
from our own experience everybody has
back problems and the reason you have
bat in fact that apparently all
vertebrates do I mean you can't ask a
cow does your back hurt but it seems
that cows have the same back problems we
have doesn't even seem to do with
upright posture and probably all large
for is some neurophysiologists believe
everything back to the shark in shark's
the last well-designed object uh and the
uh and this is a big problem you know
people suffer from it and the reason is
that the the verteb the the spine is
just extremely badly designed uh from an
engineering point of view it's a wreck
you know uh and they're in fact nowadays
when people do sp I had big spine
operation a couple years ago they don't
even do anything they did the blood clot
that forms turns out to be about as good
as the original disc so there's nothing
to do you know you just sort of let it
grow back together uh the and this is
true of just about every system of the
you know of the body let's say you know
we would be a lot better off and be able
to save ourselves from a lot of
saber-toothed tigers hundreds of
thousands of years ago who had an eye on
the back of the head let's say but we
don't you know uh we we have only eyes
in the front and rabbits have them on
the side uh but uh there's just a lot of
things that would be very useful that
aren't around for example would be very
useful to have wheels because then you'd
go really fast down flat places but
organisms don't have wheels you know
there's a lot of things they just they
just do the kinds of things they can do
and it's usually a mess uh the inorganic
world for some unexplained reason turns
out to be completely different or at
least everyone assumes that it is
they're driving intuition of say
physicists and chemists is that somehow
it's all going to come out extremely
simple
and if you have say numbers like seven
around you figure you must have made
some mistake because the only real
numbers are things like two and three so
it's really got to be eight you know two
cubed or something and that's the
driving intuition behind almost all the
study of the inorganic world and it has
been remarkably successful so there's
probably something to it why nobody
knows but it seems to be true and
language is very much like that it seems
again this could be an artifact maybe
we're fooling ourselves uh that's always
possible but it looks as if language is
very much like the kind of thing you
find in the inorganic World well that's
kind of curious because it's the most
complicated thing apparently that the
organic World produced so why does it
look like that in fact really right at
its core you already have this property
so languages a system which is
technically called a system of discrete
Infinity
means like say and it's a very simple
idea I mean say take words you can have
a six word sentence you can have a seven
word sentence but you can have a six and
a half word sentence right and every
aspect of language is like that and we
sort of take it for granted but it's a
strange fact because there's essentially
nothing in the organic world that that
meets the condition of discrete Infinity
you have plenty of continuous systems
like if you look at neural Maps they
vary continuously all over the place uh
you have plenty of finite systems like
you look at ape calls you know some
particular ape might have 49 calls or
something but systems of which are both
discrete and
infinite are very rare in fact about the
I think the only place you find anything
like it in the biological world is when
you get down to the level of big
molecules and then you're back in the
inorganic world so you look at DNA well
there's a certain sense in which it's
discrete Infinity but that's the level
where you're really talking about
biochemistry you know uh when you go
into actual biological organisms you
seem to move directly to continuity and
finiteness except for this furthermore
this seems to have other properties that
are rare if not non-existent in the
biological world
uh furthermore if these if if the
economy conditions are real and they
seem to be those of you who know
anything about
computability will no recognize right
off that you if you introduce economy
considerations you say one computation
is blocked if there's another more
economical one you introduce huge
computability problems unsolvable
computability problems so the question
is has anybody know it if the problems
are unsolvable like how do you know that
this derivation is going to block
another one which turns out very quickly
to be a problem of a very high level of
computational complexity Way Beyond
what's solvable so if it's true what it
means that large what it means is that
large parts of language must Simply Be
unusable because they will involve
computability problems it can't be
solved now in itself that's not a
surprising conclusion because we know
it's true we know that large parts of
language are just unusable in fact a
good part of the psychology of
psychological word you know
psycholinguistics the study of how
language is processed and so on uses
fixes its data things that are unusable
things like Garden Path sentences for
those of you who know this kind of stuff
those are all selections from parts of
language that are unusable and they're
interesting to test for that reason they
give you uh interesting things about
processing or learn from the part these
can be quite simple sentences they just
can't be understood you know so we know
that large and Scattered parts of
language are completely unusable that
shouldn't bother anyone who thinks about
language from the point of view of real
biology not pop biology in pop biology
everything's supposed to be usable and
well adapted remember but in the real
world everything is a mess and nothing
works at all uh it just works well
enough so you don't die you know that's
got to work well enough so you can
reproduce if it does that then you go on
but it does but nothing has to be usable
and most things aren't so the fact that
language isn't for a lot large parts of
languages aren't usable that's not a
problem in itself but it does raise an
extremely interesting question hard
question right at the Horizon now you
can formulate it it can't deal with it
uh can we demonstrate that the parts of
language that are technically
uncomputable are the part that in fact
are unusable
that's a hard question you can formulate
it but nobody knows how to study it uh
well all of these problems take us right
to the present and they raise very
interesting
a lot of people think they're kind of
paradoxes I don't know if they're
paradoxes or not but they're certainly
surprising uh it turns out that it seems
to turn out that the properties of
language that we can study the parts
that we can study just don't look like
the organic world at all they seem to
look a lot like the inorganic world for
very mysterious reasons uh and they have
these strange properties of computation
that you simply not only don't you find
in the organic world but you can't a lot
of it isn't even computable
well that's the part of language we can
study what about the part we can't study
like the part that led to the
traditional Mind Body problem no longer
formula as far as I can see because we
have no notion of body uh how do you
actually use language to
in a way in the ways that we do and we
talk to each other normally ways that
are appropriate to situations not caused
by internal States or external events
coherent intelligible to others with all
those properties that remains as it has
always been a complete mystery and why
it remains a mystery is also a mystery I
just noticed that the same is true
across the board it's true of the study
of vision it's true of the study of
motor mechanisms it's true of every
aspect of Psychology and Physiology
there is that
mysterious core which is just the
questions that we're humanly interested
in for the most part uh in which you can
only stare in puzzle that may reflect
other aspects of human cognitive
capacity May mean that just they're not
the kinds of questions we're designed to
answer uh which could be or there could
be some other reason but anyhow that's
where things stand at the moment
[Applause]
[Music]